here to tell us how we can catch the
vibe bring some positive energy and
culture into 2022. i think we all need
that right definitely yeah so so what so
what how's it been like since the last
time you were here to this one you've
been planning something yeah i've been
planning just masterminding on how to
make it a better show than before i'm
always trying to improve the show you
know so i take feedback from everybody
the funny part though is that last time
i was asking for feedback like how can
we make the show better yeah and we
didn't get any responses from it on
social media it was perfect it was it
was popping it was a good time you know
so just want to continue to make it
better even though
everybody seems to be having a great
time already so okay okay so every
evolving getting better and better each
time what can we expect from this show
on saturday just more talent coming to
the stage you know again there's some
local acts there's some out of towners
that are coming in from l.a right like
we're both familiar we just found out
that we're both from the same hood yes
yes we got some people coming in from
san francisco and all over the place so
it's just going to be oh look there's a
little last time yeah it was such a
great vibe and i just would love for
everybody to come out and spirit
experience it so we're looking at the
venue right now let's talk about
brooklyn bowling why this is the perfect
venue for such an event well it has
great production value you know we were
at a smaller venue before right and so
to come to you know brooklyn bowl it's
just a large-scale venue where you have
national acts that are torn and to be
able to put local talent that are within
the city and are talented and bring some
out of town acts and put them on the
same stage it's just a beautiful thing
to see come together so what are you
most looking forward to
this show people's expressions and then
at the same time for the for the
performers to get on stage and just see
all these people in front of them to be
able to get their you know their art out
to people that love the art that they
create yeah it's it's an incredible
feeling to be able to share that
experience with people because
everybody's winning in a sense right
everybody's winning everybody including
the audience the audience the performers
everybody loves the vibe as a whole you
know that's what it's all about that's
that's why you created this right
exactly get people on stage to you know
to give them a stage to to be seen right
we wanna we want people to connect if
you love if you love hip hop you love
poetry you're gonna love this event okay
so why 2022 why do we need to start our
year off with this with this five
because we need to get right we need to
get we need to get rid of all the bad
vibes that we've had in 2020 2021 and
start fresh and the poetry and the
hip-hop the lyrics everything that comes
together just the experience as a whole
is going to get people in the right
state of mind for 2022. i love that i
love that you don't have to say anything
else that is inspiration enough hip-hop
and poetry night is happening this
saturday night at the brooklyn bowl
doors open at seven the show starts at
eight so you can get your tickets online
hiphop and poetry.com
and i have to say now it's time for a
little taste yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna do
just a quick little piece for the people
to see what they're getting into if they
come out let me let me
have your space
all right so this piece right here is
called imagine and i'm just gonna get
right into it imagine martin luther
never there to catch a bullet imagine
never stressing over people being
crooked imagine if we spread more love
than spread hate stop shooting killing
people for nothing for god's sakes
listen imagine that you were a king
imagine if instead of spending money you
were saving everything imagine if you
told your daughter hold out for a ring
and told your son instead of women he
should go and chase a dream imagine if
instead of having people on the side all
you had was one person that was loving
you right and now imagine college
students didn't have to pay tuition
imagine never needing the amber alert
system imagine if you didn't always feel
against the eyes and single parents
didn't always need a second job imagine
you could change the past imagine
parking big still alive and the league
never crashed imagine that
[Laughter]
can we get some snatching snap it up
yeah
that's so good
thank you so much top and poetry
poetry yeah exactly exactly that was
amazing thank you so much i appreciate
it come see more this saturday are you
going to be on stage this saturday i'm
going to be on stage this saturday i'm
going to bless the stage real quick but
it's not about me it's about everybody
else the performers coming out and
giving an opportunity to just present
their work in front of everybody that's
perfect all right one more time
we have hip hop and poetry night at
brooklyn bowl this saturday january 8th
you can get your tickets at